Rise and live again as my fist of vengeance as my
moon knight
Welcome back everyone this will be my
full marvel moon knight episode 5 video there were
a whole bunch of easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes doctor strange 2 is also coming out in
theaters next week so we're doing a giveaway for
imax tickets for the movie all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all your moon
knight theories on the video below obviously a lot
of connection between what's happening with the
gods on the moon knight series what's happening
with the gods in dr strange 2 and in thor love
and thunder careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and go through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments as we go along
starting with the episode titled asylum obviously
a reference to the insane asylum that they're
trapped in which is named after the insane asylum
that he was put in as a child a lot of what we see
during the episode is a version of the comic book
origin story but they've kind of mixed and matched
things because they retconned some things in the
comics recently about the way that his family
existed when he was a child but most of this
is meant to be a reference to the original comic
book origin story but as tarewet the hippo goddess
explains in the episode the asylum is just a
mind space asylum it's a way for his mind to
perceive this alternate dimension that his soul
has traveled to as he's headed to the egyptian
ennead version of the afterlife and i'll get into
that too because this obviously gets into big
multiverse stuff it talks about different realms
different afterlifes they even make black panther
references to the astral plane you'd be surprised
how many intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist like the ancestral plane oh
just gorgeous like i said there's no coincidence
that we're getting ready to see dr strange two
multiverse of madness next week because there's
a lot of multiverse going on in this episode but
the episode is basically a true origin of moon
knight in the comics like moon knight this is your
life episode the only thing that they don't really
explain in the episode or get into that much is
what's going on with the jake lockley persona
they referenced him during the episode but most of
what you see during the episode is just the steven
grant and the marc spector personalities this
time they just play the regular fanfare music
during the marvel phase 4 intro sometimes they'll
have custom egyptian music playing over the intro
the opening scene is a marc reliving a version
of his childhood like they kind of cut quickly
through a bunch of different moments before
going back to the moment at the end of episode 4.
the waterfall is in the caves whereas a child his
brother from the comics actually died leading to
him eventually creating the steven grant persona
in the first place possibly also the jake lockley
persona but we'll get into that too the reason
why you see this quick montage play out at the
beginning of the episode then you see him back
screaming in the same moment at the end of episode
4 seeing the hippo goddess for the first time is
as they explained during the episode this happens
a couple times where he'll just jump around
back to the psychiatrist office who's obviously
a version of arthur harrow but it's in his mind
so he's the one that's doing all this to himself
it's because during any given moment they're
seeing something that marc spector doesn't want
to deal with again so it's a way for his mind to
protect itself to sort of take a quote-unquote
time out obviously the whole episode is him
learning to eventually deal with that with the
help of steven so we'll get to that but they
start to explain what he was talking about
during episode one when he was talking to steven
grant for the first time when steven was the one
who was trapped and he said he'd mostly kept him
tamped down inside him this whole time like i've
had it under control until recently one of the
big surprises of the episode is that we learned
it wasn't actually him dying and then coming
back to life forming the bargain with khonshu
becoming moon knight that actually broke his mind
the presence of this other mind it was actually
him trying to finally confront his mother's
death and that's the thing that really broke
him in why he started to lose control of himself
switching back and forth between personalities so
just to be clear even though there are a bunch of
times in the episode where you have funny scenes
with a version of arthur harrow all dressed up
with the funny mustache the real version of arthur
harrow in the real world isn't doing any of this
he's not responsible for what's happening here
this is all a fictitious creation of marc
spector's mind trying to process everything that's
happened to him the actual hospital of these in
inside his mind is called putnam medical facility
because in the comics that's the place where he
was sent as a child when he started to express
d.i.d when he started to express all these
alternate personalities that's part of the
newer version of his origin story originally in
the comics what happened is that he was just marc
spector it was just the one personality he became
a version of moon knight and then he developed
these alternate personas to pretend to be other
people to become a better superhero but eventually
switching between all them so frequently broke
his mind but then in the more recent comics they
retcon things to say that he'd always had d.i.d
and it was some childhood trauma that he suffered
where they developed the alternate personas so the
tv show is kind of combining the newer backstory
with the old original backstory the reason they
say this hospital is located in chicago illinois
is because that's where marc is from in the
comics that's where his house was as a child with
a version of his mother his younger brother his
father early in the episode he's seeing a version
of himself about two months ago as he explains
when he wasn't able to go to his mother's funeral
seeing an older version of his father as we
learned that's the same time that layla lost track
of marc spector he'd already become moon knight
she knew that he was a version of moon knight
but he just disappeared two months ago it was this
event seeing his mother's funeral and not being
able to deal with that that caused him to switch
to steven grant and he'd just been in steven grant
mode until the events of episode 1 pick up when
the fake version of arthur harrow says that marc
has created this reassuring fantasy in his head
it's meant to be a double reference both calling
him out for creating the alternate personas
in the first place as a child to deal with
the trauma but also hits his own mind making him
question the reality of moon knight and khonshu.
I talked about this in my episode 4 video but
that's also right out of the comics too where
he wound up in a version of a mental hospital
and it was really just meant to be a creation
of his own mind as a way for himself to deal
with everything that had happened to him and
reconcile all the different personalities the
only difference in the comics is that he hadn't
just died when this happened it wasn't meant to
be a version of the afterlife in the comics when
this was happening he wasn't trapped there wasn't
anything bad happening with khonshu so a lot of
what we're seeing in the episode is this conscious
mind arguing with his subconscious mind about
what's real and what's fake and actually trying
to deal with the things that happened to him
that's why the fake version of arthur harrow says
you're trying not to look within because it's him
trying to tell himself that he needs to deal with
everything the rhinoceros in the hippo that he
mentions is him joking about khonshu's appearance
in tarewet khonshu's form is more bird-like if
you want to get technical when he says the hippo
could break down the walls between marc and steven
that's literally what happens in the episode
then like i said the reason why it jumps back
to him screaming seeing tarot for the first time
is because his mind sort of comes back to reality
like oh this is actually what's happening right
now each time he jumps back to the psychiatrist
is him trying to not deal with things tarewet is
meant to be the goddess of women and children like
a gentle household type of god very benevolent
person because most of the episode is him dealing
with his childhood that's the reason why she's the
guide to the actual afterlife on the barge here
she actually explains what's going on here in
a more cosmic sense and how this all fits with
the mythology that we've been seeing in all
the marvel movies in the marvel disney plush
shows right now like this is how everything is
connected so when she says that they're actually
dead they are kind of dead they're in the space
between life and death basically like this sort
of liminal area where they're either going to the
afterlife or they're going to be trapped or they
can come back to life but that's why they're able
to see her true form as she actually exists there
are a lot of rules that the gods have imposed on
themselves inside this alternate dimension of the
overvoid where they're trapped right now they can
only appear like this inside their heads or when
they're dead although as we'll learn during thor
love and thunder there are lots of mcu gods that
are still alive and living inside the main mcu
dimension not all gods are the same power level
not all of them are created equal and the reason
why a lot of them don't get into fights with other
gods it'd be like a god tier version of avengers
end game across the multiverse across a bunch of
different dimensions so they don't want to end all
of reality and kill all their subjects and a lot
of the gods are just really lazy which is why most
guys just kind of ignore the other gods and only
think about their own worshippers but him dying
like this getting the gunshots to the chest is
also a big comic book easter egg one of the many
powers of khonshu is just flat-out resurrection
marc spector moon knight has died many times
in the comics and khonshu usually just brings
him back to life like it's no big deal khonshu can
bring him back as many times as he wants and it'll
be really important for how he comes back during
episode six in the finale obviously before that
happens layla will have to free khonshu so that
khonshu can reform their bargain and give marc
his powers back so that when he comes back to life
the bullet wounds don't immediately kill him again
but the reason why they're in duat the egyptian
realm of the dead specifically is because of his
relationship with khonshu and because of where he
died the first time that he was dying he was at
the statue of khonshu so for example a version
of this happens to the asgardians except the
place where they go when they die is an alternate
dimension of valhalla like that's where odin's
life force went the odin force him speaking to
thor in this place is kind of like the same thing
that marc and steven are experiencing now like
thor is slowly dying here so he's able to speak
to a version of odin while he's in this alternate
dimension that's why when thor is just fine he's
walking around on a normal day all casual like
he can't speak to odin tarewet literally mentions
the ancestral plane from the black panther movie
which like i said is an alternate dimension that
black panthers people and wakandu go to based on
their beliefs it's specific to boss the panther
goddess because of his people's relationship with
her black panther has a contract with the panther
goddess that grants him most of his power he can
also form a relationship with different gods and
get their powers too in umbaku for instance is
from the ape tribe in wakanda they worship the
ape god so if he were to die he would be seeing a
version of the ape god appearing to him like i've
said though boss the panther goddess is literally
the biological sister of khonshu and at various
times she's also been a member of the eniad but
just not currently in this version during the mcu
she confirms this place is a creation of their
mind and each person perceives the afterlife
as something different like i said just based on
their different belief system the different gods
that they worship it's kind of like a version of
what you saw in avengers infinity war in avengers
end game after characters snap the infinity
gauntlet each time when they do that the cosmic
force is so great even beings who are really
powerful like thanos and the hulk die briefly
then come back to life but when they're dead
they experience the way station quote-unquote the
world of the soul gem it's kind of like
what you're seeing happen here but like
tolerate talks about the intersection of all these
different planes and these different dimensions
the soul world of the soul stone holds a copy of
people's essence for people who come into contact
with it but what each person sees when they're in
there is specific to them in their life that's why
thanos saw a version of young gamora and that's
why the hulk probably saw a version of black widow
then everything that's going on with his sail
barge them traveling across the sands of duat
on their way to the actual egyptian afterlife
is right out of real world egyptian mythology
tarewet references anubis's test about balancing
their hearts to see if they're lighter than a
feather that's why on the actual scales the statue
is a statue of anubis the whole concept that if
their hearts are not lighter than the feather
that means that they've done something evil or
something is weighing on their soul originally it
was ammit's job to basically consume all the souls
of the unworthy people but when she says that they
just get trapped in the sands of dua like you see
all these sand figures zoom in enhance it's hard
to tell if there are any actual easter eggs here
so if you think you can spot who any of these
people are early in the episode just write it
below in the comments later in the episode the
people who rise up to try and pull him down into
the sands winds up being the people that he killed
when he was moon knight though but the whole idea
is that this is sort of like this giant collective
area and anybody who worships the egyptian any
pantheon gods would wind up in a version of
this place that's why later in the episode you
basically see it raining souls into this place the
reason why it's raining souls obviously is because
ammit has somehow escaped her captivity and
physically returned into the mcu and can do that
instantly to almost everybody that's why at the
end of the episode she says oh all these souls are
winding up here before it's their time before they
were meant to die the whole thing with the scale
not balancing because they haven't dealt with
their past they have these alternate personalities
that are kind of at war with each other was also
referenced in episode one when arthur harrow tried
to judge him in the same scales on his arm the
tattoo just would not balance then as they start
traveling back through marc's memories as a child
they see all the dead bodies of the people that he
killed when he was moon knight just saying that
they kind of haunt him metaphysically then you
travel back to marc's childhood when his brother
was still alive his brother is from the comics
he's named randall spector now in the comics he
was a much bigger character he lives to adulthood
he becomes a version of shadow knight and part of
the cult of khonshu he also kind of went crazy and
stole the powers of moon knight from marc spector
for a brief period sounds like they're not going
to do that in the mcu any time soon though because
as they explain he died as a child and that led
to his trauma eventually developing the d.i.d
his father was a jewish rabbi also right out
of the comics now what they've done on the show
though is they've given more backstory to his
mother in the comics you don't really learn quite
this much about what was going on with his mom
all the stuff with his brother dying his mother
abusing him as a child that's brand new stuff that
they've created just for the tv show but as you
see as they travel through these memories there's
lots of references to the egyptian gods and what's
happening in present day they say the rhine later
gators seeing a wild crocodile that's another
reference to ammit who has the head of a crocodile
it's not related to alligator loki because
alligators are a different species than crocodiles
they reference rosser rosser was the little
kid in that fictional tomb buster vhs movie
we learned the movie was actually real and
served as the basis for the steven grant persona
it'd be like a little kid today developing d.i.d
and then one of his alternate personalities
believes that he is one of these characters in one
of the marvel movies but for those of you asking
about the weird british accent this is where
it comes from the accent is basically like a
little kid doing his best version copying the fake
accent that the actor was using during that movie
so it's meant to be like a copy of a copy
of someone doing a fake interpretation of
a british accent and that's why it sounds so weird
as they're traveling to the cave steven steps onto
the skeleton which is meant to resemble conscious
form just kind of subconsciously reminding him
about what's happening in real life you see his
brother dying when the caves start to overflow
and then they sort of jump cut to the wake as we
learned the steven grant persona was developed as
sort of a defense mechanism so that's why steven
is learning about all this backstory for the first
time because he wasn't meant to know about it we
see a quick montage of his mother getting worse
and worse over the years just slowly abusing him
until he develops full-blown d.i.d when he gets
old enough and leaves they sort of jump over a
little bit of backstory because when they're in
the desert here this is basically the original
origin story but he does kind of explain what
happened to him and it's pretty close to the comic
book origin story what happened in the comics is
that he joined the military then he joined the cia
then he became a mercenary then he got the moon
knight origin in the mcu the only difference
is that he joined the military when awol
then became a mercenary so he just kind of skipped
over the cia stuff all the stuff with bushmen is
mostly accurate the only difference is that in the
military bushman was his ceo in the comics he was
just another random mercenary that had hired him
but the whole idea is that even before he started
killing people as mooney when he was a mercenary
he earned a ton of money doing really shady
stuff and that in the comics was the way that he
funded his playboy lifestyle as steven grant who
was meant to be this millionaire playboy persona
little different on the tv show but you could draw
a connection to iron man being the billionaire
playboy philanthropist genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist we see a version of the classic
origin story basically play out with the aftermath
of bushmen going rogue killing layla's father
marc also dying trying to protect them and then
dragging himself to conscious statue so the tomb
that he was originally hired to raid was khonshu's
tomb one of the big twists though is that he's so
remorseful for what he's done and what's happened
recently with layla's father is that he tries
to kill himself as khonshu tries to speak to him
he forms the bargain then gets all the powers
of moon knight but when steven says khonshu took
advantage of you that's also a reference in the
comics to the newer backstory which is a bit of a
retcon but the new backstory basically says that
khonshu had been waiting this entire time for a
good opportunity to take advantage of a person who
had a weak mental state who was very fragile so he
saw marc spector as a child develop a version
of d.i.d and just kind of waited for the right
opportunity to take advantage of that and make
him his avatar so khonshu had been targeting marc
spector his entire life not just recently but when
they come back to tarewet they see all the purple
energy of souls around the world just in mass
coming into the afterlife the whole thing that's
going on here is that arthur harrow has found
a way to release ahmed and she started to end
mass judge everyone the whole idea is that they
have tarewet find a way to contact layla and use
osiris gate in the afterlife to get back to the
world of living they want layla to be the one to
free khonshu so that when they actually do come
back to life inside their body he has his powers
so that the bullet wounds won't be a big deal like
his healing factor will just take care of all that
we actually just saw osiris's avatar in the
earlier episodes he's the one who was placing
khonshu's statue on the pedel he's one of the
greater gods in their pantheon of the enid and
he's supposed to be the god of the afterlife which
is why it's his gate that they have to travel
through to get back to the world of the living
but when i talk about the world of the living
it's kind of like them traveling across different
states of existence different dimensions across
the multiverse it'd be like the same thing if thor
died and was traveling to a version of valhalla
marc doesn't want to go back and watch himself
be beaten as a child so badly that he freaks
out that's why it sort of jump cuts back into
arthur harrow's fake psychiatrist office here
and why it's steven seeing him for the first time
too because he's also got to reconcile the idea
that his mother isn't alive it's all part of them
balancing the scales like obviously mostly this
is marc trying to deal with his past childhood
trauma and developing d.i.d but also on the same
side there's a bunch of stuff that steven has
to make peace with too like oh i'm not the real
one and my mother is dead when he's making peace
with the idea of his mother actually being dead
the person that they tell to dial the phone number
dylan is actually a representation of the woman
in the museum that he asked out on a date while
in a different persona steven grant also makes a
funny simpsons ned flanders reference when he's
describing arthur harrow's mind space look with
the funny looking mustache he does kind of look
like ned flanders you notice when they go back
into this memory and he's a little kid getting
ready to get beaten by his mother you see a
version of the scales of justice behind him just
sort of foreshadowing what's happening in present
day you see the actual tomb buster poster which is
the inspiration for the fictional steven grant and
you see him as a child switch between different
personalities then like i said charting the
timeline they go back to two months ago when his
mother actually died he goes back but he's unable
to go in he's in marc spector form he's already
become moon knight he's already met layla for
the first time and it just winds up breaking him
and he switches between different personalities
into full steven grant mode and he's been that way
for the past two months and that's why layla lost
track of him she was only able to track him down
when he found marc spector's phone and activated
it there's a blink and you'll miss it jake lockley
referenced during all this too there's a cab
driving by him while he's breaking down switching
between different personalities jake lockley was
a cab driver in the comics but they don't ever
explain what was happening with the alternate
personality in the episode because this is mostly
just a steven and marc episode it sounds like we
won't actually see him surface in the body until
the finale they might explain that he's either
been there the whole time and he's just been even
more suppressed or he developed persona when he
completely broke here at his mother's wake then
the whole big action scene with everything going
crazy and the scale's not balancing and the bodies
coming up like i said is basically the bodies of
the people that he killed previously while he was
the avatar of country while he was moon knight
then there's this whole crazy thing with one of
them winding up in the actual afterlife in the
field of reeds and one of them being trapped
in the sand the reason why it happens this way
the reason why the scale is balanced and one of
them is able to do this is because both of them
realize that they're the same person and they
reconcile with their traumatic past and all the
lies they've been telling themselves that's why
steven is able to sacrifice himself using some of
marc spector's skills like he has access to
them and the reason why marc spector is the
person who winds up inside the field of reads and
not steven grant is because technically he is the
original personality like he is the real person
but while this is happening while both of them
are being trapped in these different alternate
dimensions tarewet is busy trying to contact the
version of layla to free khonshu so that khonshu
can rescue marc spector resurrect him and he'll
have his powers again so that the bullet wounds
won't kill him when he actually comes back to life
it sounds like most of that stuff with layla
in real life will take place pretty quickly
during the events of episode one and then they'll
sort of spin up to like a full blown moon knight
versus arthur harrow powered action scene like you
would expect in a big marvel battle and as part of
that we'll also probably get to see a version of
khonshu and the other gods doing something about
ahmed like moon knight vs arthur harrow and gods
vs gods if you spotted any other big easter eggs
in the episode or you have big questions that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments i'll post a finale
trailer video next in my full moon knight episode
6 finale video we'll post next week just like
normal next week is also when doctor strange 2
is coming out in theaters so i'll be posting my
non-spoilery review video tuesday morning make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss that everyone click here for my new doctor
strange 2 iron man and living tribunal video
and click here for all my moon knight episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!